C’était le 4 juillet 2015, aux US, à Boston.
Et en voyant les lumières des feux d’artifice
tomber,
je n’ai pas honte de dire que j’ai eu
une petite pensée
Pour le grand très grand Isaac Newton.
Car les magnifiques couleurs de mille feux
N’était autre que le chainon manquant entre
le quotidien des hommes,
Qui est aussi le monde très terre-à-terre
de la pomme,
Et le royaume divin des cieux.
Mais pour comprendre ce à quoi je pense,
Il me faut revenir autour des années 1630,
Au moment où trois géants des sciences
Révélèrent un tas d’indices très intrigants…
Pour commencer, au Pays-Bas,
René Descartes fit une formidable décourverte
mathématiques,
À savoir l’unification de la géométrie
de la Grèce Antique,
Et de l’algèbre du monde Arabe.
Dès lors, les objets géométriques
Pouvaient être manipulées via des équations
algébriques.
Pour Newton, la géométrie algébrique de
Descartes était du pain béni
Il l’approfondit en inventant un tout nouvel
objet mathématique qu’on appelle la dérivée
Cette invention est souvent associée à la
naissance des mathématiques avancées,
Enfin commença-t-on à maîtriser le potentiel
de l’infini !
En particulier, armé de sa nouvelle mathématique,
Newton put enfin donner un sens précis
À des concepts auparavant flous comme la
vitesse ou l’accélération
Et ainsi enfin les intégrer dans des équations.
Ensuite, en Italie,
Comme nous l’avions déjà dit,
Non seulement Galilée a prouvé que les objets
tombent tous aussi vite,
Mais il caractérisa aussi la trajectoire
de ces objets en chute libre.
Pour tout objet, cette trajectoire est celle
d’une parabole.
Et l’étude de ces paraboles conduisit Newton
à une conclusion assez folle.
En dérivant la hauteur d’une pomme par
le temps par deux fois,
Newton découvrit que la parabole était la
trajectoire d’une accélération constante
vers le bas.
C’était une incroyable prouesse !
Galilée et Newton avaient unifié les chutes
de toute chose,
En notant, que, qu’importe son poid, sa
forme, sa position, sa vitesse,
Qu’importe s’il va vers le bas ou vers
le haut,
Tout objet en chute libre gagne 10 mètres
par seconde vers le bas à chaque seconde.
Newton alla encore plus loin, avec une idée
qui deviendra incroyablement féconde.
Les forces, se dit-il, n’affectent ni les
vitesses des objets, ni leurs positions.
Elles ne peuvent affecter que leurs accélérations.
Tel est le principe fondamental de la dynamique
que Newton mathématisa.
Vous savez, F=ma.
Enfin, à Prague, le grand astronome Johannes
Kepler
Analysa minutieusement les trajectoires des
planètes,
Dans un modèle héliocentrique de l’univers.
Après des années à calculer comme une bête,
Kepler renonça aux cercles et aux épicycles.
Qu’il remplaça par des ellipses.
Oui, des ellipses.
Mais pourquoi des ellipses ?
Telle est la question que l’astronome Edmond
Haley posa à un Newton âgé.
Newton répondit nonchaleusement qu’il l’avait
déduit de sa théorie de la gravité !
Et en particulier, du fait que la gravité
décroît en 1 sur la distance au carré.
Mais de quoi es-tu en train de parler ? Comment
est-ce que tu le sais ? Se demanda Haley.
Bah il y a 20 ans, Newton répondit, je l’avais
calculé.
Et oui ! En étudiant les trajectoires elliptiques
de Kepler,
Newton avait déjà deviné la loi de la gravité
de l’univers !
Mais il n’avait pas pris le temps de le
dire à qui que ce soit !
Haley en resta pantois.
Il supplia Newton de publier sa théorie du
mouvement et de la gravitation,
Et promit de payer pour tous les frais de
publications.
Newton accepta, et se mit à travailler dur,
très très dur,
Pendant les 18 mois qui suivirent.
Il introduisit méticuleusement ses nouvelles
mathématiques au fur et à mesure,
Et paracheva un livre au destin historique.
Ce livre commence par énoncer quatre lois
éternelles.
Les trois premières sont les lois du mouvement,
Celles dont on a parlé dans un épisode précédent,
Et la quatrième est la loi de la gravitation
universelle.
De façon cruciale, Newton prouva que cette
quatrième loi de l’univers
n’était pas plus divine dans le ciel que
sur Terre.
Les lois de l’au-delà
étaient les mêmes que celles d’ici-bas.
En particulier, et de façon contraire à
toute intuition,
Tout comme la pomme, la Lune tombe constamment
vers la Terre !
Pour imager cette brillante réflexion,
Pour illustrer cette incroyable unification
de toutes les pièces de l’univers,
En un monde unique régi par la seule et même
loi de la gravitation,
Newton conçut l’expérience de pensée
dite du boulet de canon.
Mais je vais utiliser des feux d’artifice
moi.
Si un feu explose doucement, alors il retombe
selon une trajectoire parabolique.
C’est l’une des raisons pour lesquelles
j’ai trouvé ce spectacle si magnifique
!
S’il explosait fortement, alors, en principe,
le feu pourrait retomber à plusieurs kilomètres.
S’il explosait encore plus fortement, alors
il pourrait aller à des milliers de kilomètres.
Mais comme la Terre est ronde, la trajectoire
du feu ne sera pas parabolique !
Si le feux explosait encore plus fort — allez
pourquoi pas, on fait de la physique théorique
—
Alors le feu pourrait faire le tour de la
Terre, et suivrait une trajectoire… elliptique
!
Tout comme une planète autour du Soleil !
Cette expérience de pensée est vraiment
une pure merveille !
Elle montre bien qu’une seule et unique
loi de la gravitation
Suffisait à expliquer à la fois la chute
de la pomme, et l’orbite des planètes.
C’était une incroyable démonstration.
Mais surtout, les physiques mathématiques
allaient désormais être à la fête,
Cette mathématisation des lois de la Nature
était un projet absolument fantastique,
Qui pendant les siècles qui ont suivis,
Allait être consolidées par des générations
de très grands génies,
Qui exploitèrent toujours plus le potentiel
monstrueux des mathématiques,
Et révélèrent ainsi un univers plus contre-intuitif,
Plus mystérieux et plus incompréhensible,
plus extraordinaire et plus étranger,
que ce que Newton lui-même n’aurait jamais
pu imaginer…
Newton a dit : « Je ne sais pas ce que je
suis aux yeux du monde, mais à mes yeux,
je semble n'avoir été qu'un garçon jouant
le long de la plage, et se divertissant de
temps à autre à trouver un caillou plus
lisse ou un coquillage plus joli que d'ordinaire,
alors que le grand océan de la vérité s'étendait
sans fin, inconnu, devant moi ».
Il ajouta : « Si j’ai vu plus loin que
d’autres, c’est en me tenant sur les épaules
de géants. »